look what do you say to all these people
that think they can do social media
easily the word hustle I'm hoping is
going to come out so I think the answer
is hustle so I think listen I think work
ethic you know I I love it I really do
think that people grossly underestimate
the balance between work ethic and
talent right talent gets you to a
certain place and then there's another
variable to it and so I'm a big fan of
it specifically within social we I'm
starting to realize very recently this
is one of the first few times I've ever
saying this we got caught web 1.0 and
2.0 were very automated and very quick
results driven if you've been on the web
for the last decade or 15 years
something we got caught because email
marketing SEO and SEM banner retargeting
all this stuff worked quickly if you
want I mean the reason I built a
business from 3 to 60 was because I
email marketed when nobody else did and
I have 88% open rates right I mean like
cuz it was new and nobody was doing it
so we had this web revolution where
things you know you did something and
you got quick results then it would
short into this thing called social
media and it's actually the opposite
social media is human your best
relationships didn't happen overnight
maybe some of your most fond ones but
not your best ones right and so we're
we're caught is Jab Jab Jab right hook
give give give and then ask
we're coming from web 100 and web 200
which was ask ask ask ask ask ask ask
and because it was new and highly
effective and quite targeted in
comparison to print radio television
outdoor it converted quite well you know
you landed one in every four of those
right hooks pretty good ratio compared
to the one in every 500 that traditional
media did remember I built a lot of my
library on traditional media I'm not a
new-age kid I love print and radio and
television and direct mail still today
my problem is it's all overpriced old
traditional media right now is priced as
if we live in 2002 instead of 2014
that's the only problem
Abbadon I'd still run a commercial if
they charge me the appropriate price in
a world where everybody DVRs and PBRs
end or if a commercial is lucky to break
through all the new technology the
second one comes up you grab your phone
and you're looking down and you're not
paying attention so you know to me the
I've never had I mean the people that
set Auto DMS to their Twitter accounts I
want to stab in the throat the people
that think that like you can automate
human touch are wrong and that's why
they've struggled with it they try most
people are applied
I truly believe most people are applying
SEO and SEM eat banner targeted ad email
marketing psychology to social which is
why they're not getting results